this November Captain Marvel is going to
get pretty dark
Marvel Comics recently announced the
story arc entitled the last Avenger
which will run in the pages of Captain
Marvel beginning with issue number 12
the arc will find Carol Danvers hunting
down her fellow Avengers and at least
one of them will die by her hand early
in the proceedings the official synopsis
for the arc offers no explanation other
than to say that annihilating the
Avengers will be a pretty big deal
Captain Marvel has fought off alien
hordes rescued x-men punched Thanos in
the face literally saved the world she
now faces her greatest challenge killed
the Avengers as one of the world's most
powerful heroes gone dark but why and
what does this mean for Carole for the
world life on earth will never be the
same
wait till you see this next one
everybody to doom
maybe it won't get that bad but as to
why she would be forced to turn against
her teammates and even go so far as to
execute one or more of them we can only
guess it wouldn't be the first time
either Marvel fans know that Captain
Marvel was forced to fight her fellow
heroes during the events of Civil War
two the art comes courtesy of writer
Kelly Thompson who was worked on a
number of Marvel titles including a
force hawkeye Jessica Jones and West
Coast Avengers Thompson has been in
charge of Captain Marvel since the
title's relaunch earlier this year and
while she's had an awesome run she's the
first to admit that she hasn't exactly
conditioned readers to expect the kind
of mega bomb she intends to drop on them
with issue number 12 speaking with comic
book calm Thompson said Carole is an
incredibly powerful character and you
can really push her to the furthest edge
and you sort of need to in order to keep
things interesting and that's what we're
trying to do with the last Avenger I
think it's going to be a terrific Carol
story that really highlights her
strengths as a character and maybe some
weaknesses as well it's a little risky
but I'm excited I hope people love it we
won't be able to crack open issue number
12 until it hit stands in November but
the synopsis for issue number 13 was
recently released as well and it clues
us into the fact that it's going to get
pretty dark pretty fast reading one
Avenger is dead at Captain Marvel's hand
who will be next and why
what strange Allegiance is driving
Captain Marvel to the darkest edge
Marvel has a long history of good
characters going bad from the iconic
x-men story arc Dark Phoenix which
formed the basis for this year's movie
of the same name two spider-man's tango
with the symbiote which would eventually
become
but the idea of Captain Marvel turning
on her friends is a truly scary one
especially since she's one of the most
insanely powerful characters in the
entire Marvel Universe just like her
Marvel Cinematic Universe counterpart
she has strength and durability on par
with the Hulk can discharge pure energy
perhaps more effectively than Thor and
can fly faster than Iron Man she's a bit
like all of the Avengers wrapped into
one and if she's truly gotten it into
her head to wipeout
Earth's Mightiest Heroes there might not
be a heck of a lot anybody can do to
stop her of course Carole isn't just
going to break bad for no reason and we
can only guess as to why she does visit
mind control I Captain Marvel from an
alternate reality a really bad day an
alien virus or is this mysterious
Allegiance imply that Carole isn't
working on her own but who and for what
purpose Captain Marvel number 12 hit
stands in digital platforms on November
20th and that's when the fun begins
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superheroes are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]